it's like when you learn a second
language and you start to understand
syntax and grammar and symbols and
meaning and you see a second Intel form
of intelligence and we start to
understand the taxonomy of intelligence
yeah let's start to maybe understand
ourself I think a lot of us think humans
like intelligence is one of the gifts
that tends to set us apart in certain
realms and but so maybe getting a lens
to understand that betters is a really
empowering area and then further I feel
like many of us are living in almost
like a little bit of a dystopia with
illusions of freewill and are stuck
doing things are driven by different
external forces and what if you could
unlock from some of that to really
pursue your your own fulfilling and
creative pursuits boom what's up
everyone welcome to simulation I'm your
host Allen sockin we are on-site at the
sandbox in the beautiful San Diego
California we are now going to be
talking about human AI collaboration we
have Alex Bates joining us on the show
hi Alex
great to be with you today thank you so
much for coming on the show so pumped
for this conversation those who don't
know alphas background he is the
managing director at neocortex ventures
technology chair at the sandbox a member
of the Forbes Technology Council an
author of augmented mind previously he
was CTO of MTEL which was acquired by
Aspen tech and you find all the links in
the Bible o to new cortex ventures
dot-com the sandbox AI as well as the
augmented mind book link all right now
so let's start things off by asking one
of our favorite questions what is your
thoughts on the direction of our world I
am actually a huge optimist which I know
seems like a contrarian perspective
lately but I see lots of challenges and
actually see amazing technologies and
solutions coming out and see humans
rising to the to the challenge so
actually super super optimistic about
the potential so there's as though
there's this like pressing pressure
cooker consciousness evolution that's
happening where we have to like win this
wisdom race there's like exponential
technologies being democratized and the
potential for malevolence occurring is
like even more so than what we
experienced with the Cold War and and
nuclear bombs and so like you're very
optimistic about us being able to win
that wisdom race evolved consciously
fast enough I am I mean I know as a
species we've gone through some pretty
major cataclysmic near cataclysmic
events I think we always rise to the
occasion I think there's there's large
challenges but sometimes necessity is
the mother of invention and I feel like
that the rising pressure will actually
help us evolve and rise to the occasion
I love it I love it and then what would
you say is a principle that you think
could be widely embodied to help us rise
to the occasion that's a great question
I feel like actually excess sort of
negativity or fear and doubt can
actually become a self-fulfilling
prophecy so I feel like mindset of not
just shutting down and in fear is an
important part of it when I was a young
engineer I thought none of that stuff
matters soft factors but actually as
I've grown and aged I've
you mentioned the wisdom part I think
that I've discovered how important that
really is when you approach these kinds
of problems that's a really good one
that fear and doubt can be
self-fulfilling prophecies so to really
just clean our channels and clear them
of those and really bring in that love
and that harmony and that peace and
butterfly effect that out to other
people and watch our world class evolve
I love that now let's let's talk about
your journey so you were born in
Portland in Oregon that's that and you
grew up there for a good chunk of your
life did a little bit of six states in
six years you said six cities four
states four five six 80s okay and like
who were you as a kid growing up that
got you interested in what you care
today I think there were a few of these
just imprint moments I remember my going
through visiting my grandfather in New
York and raiding his bookshelf in these
books about philosophy of mind and then
my uncle this mathematician and we would
just debate these topics about the mind
and even things like the soul and and
but he wasn't afraid of science at all
so I just remember all these and and I
remember also hearing stories about the
people behind math and science and that
was really fascinating to me is how they
came to these kind of Eureka moments and
and it just and at some point became
sort of obsessed with the mind and brain
and they're all networks and kind of
went from there and when you were seeing
there these moments of like epiphany or
of just deep Eureka what were the things
that you noticed about them that caused
those and what did you get interested
about them yeah there were some
interesting just patterns there so for
example almost none of them happened in
an office at a whiteboard right so our
committees and the Baths people getting
on a bus walking in nature unplugging
disconnecting switching out of the air
conic tasks positive orientation so
which actually most of our work
environments are not at all
set up to facilitate but yes I thought
it was so interesting it was usually
when you're unplugging that you're
really primed for those those kinds of
discovery moments that when we're when
when we take a a moment of silence and
you you call them you so test positive
like what that we're doing task task
oriented things so when we kind of
unplug from those into more moments of
silence or solitude or just beamed
basically mm-hmm we're just being and
when we just be it gives our it gives us
the time and space we need to do those
profound free associations and then be
like ah ha stuff like that totally yeah
like the kind of mind wandering there
seems to be this
process sometimes people think it's
linked to the default mode Network but
almost a little bit subconscious in
nature but undirected mind wandering
which we think of is wasting time but
actually it turns out maybe is one of
the most important things we need to
give ourselves free them to do
undirected mind wandering I love that
that's a great way to put it it's also
like that the balance the strike is hard
here between undirected mind wandering
and not so it's like how do you pick
whether to work for four hours on
neocortex ventures or go on a hike for
four hours and which one will accelerate
your Northstar journey the most these
are very tough questions so how do you
know when to mind wander for an hour
versus to test positive for an hour that
is a very tough question I I don't know
if there's a simple answer I did see a
lot of these aha moments from at least
like some of the Nobel Prize winners and
so on that have written about it it was
after a rigorous period of study
sometimes 10,000 hours right a decade
almost like a decade but now you've
absorbed and embodied all of the
detailed first principle understanding
of a subject area now now I'm not saying
we're 10,000 hours before you go for a
hike many means but there could be many
Eureka's on the way to maybe your huge
life-altering one but but yeah so it's
an interesting thing so you need you
probably you need to do some focused
task positive concentration to think
about maybe an area you really want to
solve a problem and but and it probably
the frequency maybe is a little personal
to each person I mean sometimes when you
hit a wall is when all whether it's
fatigue exhaustion burnout or just and
you think you know sometimes I'm just
gonna push through it but actually maybe
actually go take a walk at that point
and you'll be surprised like let your
subconscious mind kick in and it's it's
this engine there working for you eleven
bozos aren't even aware of it mm-hmm and
then what about you know leading up into
these last like even just pre MTEL days
how did you get so
with this human AI collaboration I mean
I think back a lot of the discoveries in
science I was always fascinated by the
people and the stories behind how they
came to these and when I went into AI
and and neural networks and so on there
was some amazing breakthroughs but it
became clear human mathematicians and
physicists were still at the pinnacle of
the profession and so it just became
clear why why is it that after 60 years
of AI humans are still so good at these
things and we're just starting to
understand those human gifts and I think
it was a series of discoveries of how
actually amazing are our human gifts are
which isn't really well publicized or
told in a mainstream and then there's
certainly some amazing gifts for AI and
machine learning as well which a lot of
which are complementary so it was like a
series of observations and it MTEL I was
both building the machine learning and
the neural networks but then going out
later in our company and into the field
and working with the human users and
these factories and drilling rigs and
developed us this huge appreciation for
for their intuition and what they
brought to the table and thought it's
important to recognize that that was 11
years event all right that's right yeah
that's and so you were the CTO and you
also so let's talk about this this is I
love the way that you describe this so
it's almost as though we can use this
sensor suite to to predict the
malfunctioning or failure of mechanical
equipment we can then it then we can
interject and prescribe some sort of a
solution that can prevent the the
failure from happening and this is
always also telling you about this
before we went on that I care so much
about the same process for the biometric
state of the body so predicting
pathologies and intervening to not get
to that point of like failure within the
body
so tell us about how that came to be
you guys go any fourth and making that
happen where you said love like inside a
factories and oil rigs and whatnot where
got used and then just how cool it was
to see how you know humans were the ones
that still had to go and and see what
the sensor had detected and go and do
the replacement didn't whatnot so tell
us about that
yeah well it's interesting because I
actually early in my career actually as
an undergraduate I downloaded some
research and it and published a little
bit in the area of biomedical
diagnostics in this case for early
detection of glaucoma which can cause
blindness but it turned out that you had
these noisy datasets but you could apply
different types of mathematical
computational techniques to detect it
but I remember it was interesting seeing
the trade-offs there as far as
sensitivity versus specificity and false
alarms but but we were able to get a
signal in the noise and that kind of
thing but going in with MTEL there's
this concept of descriptive analytics
which is mostly characterizing what's
happened the past predictive where
you're maybe trying to predict
something's going to happen but you
don't know exactly you can't very well
characterized the mechanisms you maybe
know something's gonna happen in a year
but you can't get down to the detailed
mechanisms prescriptive analytics which
you just mentioned so coming up with a
prescription or an intervention is the
highest value most important and yet the
least often achieved and that's where
these these people we're so key and it's
it's one one thing that's kind of a
funny paradox is if you think back to
the Minority Report four exerts all
right yeah the movie one already report
you have the precogs that make a
prediction and the pre-crime unit Tom
Cruise goes out to stop it similarly in
our realm right so we were like the
Precog we'd predict this compressor is
gonna fail in forty five days if our
software worked right we would falsify
our prediction which means we didn't
prescribed here's how you avoid this and
then it almost leads to a funny thing
like what was I gonna fail but over time
you prove that was
mystics in mean time between failure and
so on but it's interesting so with
prescriptive you're literally trying to
change the future and and yet that's
whether it's human health or machine
health that's really the Holy Grail
that's that's what you want to do
that's like actionable yes yes and this
is also so evidently seen with how we
can at all these little like bifurcating
moments of like our life trajectory that
we can pick to do certain things that
alter our life outcomes are we and this
can be as simple as just on a day to day
basis that I pick to actually sleep the
eight hours or that I only sleep for how
do I feel the next day and that same
thing with what I chose to eat that day
did I eat junk and fast food or did I
eat healthy nutrition raw raw foods
these different sorts of nuts like
that's a daily feedback loop that you
feel but it's also you can on a
longevity clock you can also see
yourself either shaving off days if
you're choosing bad habits so this is
all this is all critical at those
bifurcating rooms did you listen to a
mentor or did you take a risk
a couple risks to open a couple doors
for yourself so this is super applicable
to even our you know our trajectories
towards their divine purposes on the
planet what were some of the examples
you gave up compressing a compressor as
an example give us some more of these
examples because this is now becoming
more and more like sensors and factories
and they're now becoming all over the
place especially with IOT era
yeah we've really evolved towards closer
to ubiquitous sensing and of course
storage of sensor data and all the the
kind of prerequisites to be able to go
in with large-scale machine learning and
look at these problems ironically these
machines are way farther along and
maturity than humans when it comes to
sensing infrastructure right I I this my
ring is measuring my heart right now and
it's tracking sleep and occasion where a
few other sensors but these compressors
might have 400 hmm and so it'd be nice
when the sensing for us humans catches
up right I feel like we're pretty
valuable too but anyway yeah so the the
tons of sensing infrastructure which of
course was invaluable where there were
some complications were the labeling
almost
actually in digital health now one
challenge is electrical health records
because there's a lot of unstructured
text and doctors write things
differently similar challenge and
maintenance where the way they wrote
what happened what repair
they didn't weren't quite as rigorous or
consistent so similar actual challenges
in the two we did used to joke that
thank God we're not looking at humans
because humans have a stress and mind
state loop into our healthy mentioned
feedback and your your mind state and
and your your sort of mental health can
actually have huge impact on your
physical health and as far as we know
these machines didn't have that extra
complication but certainly there were
other complications that we had to solve
in that in that space but but yeah now
now looking ahead to humans I think huge
opportunities and some unique things
with it with our mental state too and
then you guys were taking the data from
the sensor suite and processing it in
real time to get feedback out to the
operators that was kind of the loop
that's correct I mean we might take ten
years of history of sensor data to train
up our models but the nice thing is we
can learn for example a pattern of a
bearing failure or ANATEL or failure on
one pup and transferred across the
entire fleet yeah so we wouldn't have to
wait till every pump at historical
failure it was almost like it a
distributed immune system you pick up an
immunity for one antigen on one
transferred across actually each of us
has a learning immune system but
unfortunately we can't transfer that
across each other but we were able to do
this digitally with that so kind of a
little bit of transfer learning like in
terms of me not touching something hot
and then you going like damn that [ __ ]
hurt him that's right a little bit but
yeah that's it that's a good one like
you being able to fight off some sort of
a bug I would love to be able to take
your immune response and also yeah embed
it in and just distribute that knowledge
to other people yeah that's that's
that's a good way to put it - I like
that way okay but then how did okay I'm
tell got acquired by Aspen tech and then
you ended up working with in Aspen tech
for a while on that transitionary
process yeah I did a two-year period
back with the parent company before I
moved on so and then what was the like
moving on like where what happened
within you where you were like it's time
I think I mean there was some some just
low-level things involving a retention
package and a vesting schedule but above
and beyond that huge respect for Aspen
tech actually learned a lot they spun
out of MIT in the 80s and they at the
time it had sort of the largest amount
of chemical engineers in the world that
were they did software to simulate and
then run and optimize all the worldwide
chemical and refining plants and it's
massive massive industries and so I
learned a lot they also had one of the
highest profit margins of any publicly
traded company and the fiscal discipline
was amazing to see but at the same time
as an entrepreneurial technologist you
know doing budgeting and forecasts and
and all that wasn't really that was too
much of the public company perspective
so I learned a huge amount but I think
got to the point where I wrote a huge
believer in small teams and the ability
to make big impact in effects so I had I
knew I knew that that was more of my
pull and then also really on the
investing side the ability to also
leverage that into other investing in
small teams and letting them grow as
well okay and then what about the first
and moments of you know okay well I'm
it's time I'm departing I'm ready to do
small teams and make big change with
that what were what were those ideas
that were kicking in the fur you know
how did how did it you know new cortex
ventures how did sandbox AI how did
argument in mind how did these things
come up yeah it's actually it's an
interesting evolution there because
after the exit I can't I did have some
more time on my hands it wasn't the
hundred hour work weeks anymore and so
on and so I formed this sort of a GI
mastermind group and it was a collection
about ten people and a lot of them had
both some research background but also
some frontline experience launching
startups and seeing real world adoption
effects and so on and they each came
from different backgrounds I'm a
robotics somewhere human computer
somewhere
neuro tech all these different kind of
orient areas and we'd meet once a month
and talk about paths to super
intelligence or artificial general
intelligence and so some of the impetus
for the book was actually kind of
crowdsourcing getting a finger on the
pulse within the AI community and then
of course I had one from with the
mainstream from the media and so on and
I just saw this big disconnect between
what was kind of being portrayed and
what I saw you know in the front front
lines or the ground with respect to what
is today's day I was doing and how it
was complimentary and so really a lot of
the perspectives for the book came from
you know diving in with that group
discussing these things and I guess you
could think of it as partly it was
probably a call to action within the AI
community and then partly getting a
message out outside the AI community as
well whoa okay the mastermind for paths
to AGI that's a really interesting
transition yeah whoa okay and then okay
as that's these gatherings are happening
in your masterminding these paths then
did it all so like what I'm so curious
about both what were the different
conversations about the paths they egi
and then also how did like neocortex
Ventures in sandbox and I went to mines
how did those come up
yeah well the yes a lot of the
conversations were about where we've had
wins and where we have not had wins and
there is a lot of non wins so people in
the AI community know that we've had
some great wins and we kind of have
halfway self-driving cars and voice
recognition voice assistance but we know
there's a huge list of accomplishments
that we have not yet hit and so we've
all heard about hype life cycles and so
on but a lot of our conversations or why
haven't we gone faster in these areas
and and why have we gone fast in certain
other areas so it was kind of dissecting
that and some of it had to do with where
we had ample data and
there were more concrete things and
circumscribed domains like gaming where
it's it's less of an open system with
uncertainties and feedback loops and
things that complicate the ability for
AI to thrive but so that was a lot of
the perspectives there and there were a
number of people that had perspectives
on human AI collaborations some people
were part of that DARPA funded Kate
Powell project which became Kayla with
SSRI the spun out Siri and some other
technologies so we had some of the kind
of DARPA military perspective on it and
then some other perspectives but yeah I
think then I really helped me motivate
to decide both to write a book and to
launch so neocortex Ventures and the
sandbox were born as just a mechanism to
fund technologies in the space both to
accelerate progress but also to fund the
human AI kind of augmentation aspect and
the sandbox was born as a physical
accelerator with office space where we
could plug people in and give him a
space and a network of mentors and
typically invest as well yeah that made
the spin-offs now the spin outs now
makes sense now did what was it was
there specific order like in terms of
augmented mind the neocortex version 10
sandbox or did they all kind of happen
around the same time how did that work
neocortex Ventures was was launched
first that was sort of launched as a
really underground kind of thing pretty
early on but then I started working on
the the book to crystallize the ideas
from these mastermind group meetings and
and also to to really dive into the
research on what are the human gifts and
what are the the AI gifts and how at a
detailed level could they be
complimentary and so yeah and then the
sandbox were also launched around the
same time when my colleague Shane SCAF
here was one of the key people to push
that and I came on as a partner to it to
help with that as well and then what are
some of those human gifts and what
some of the AI gifts that's it's an
interesting one it turns out and this is
something I don't think is very well
discussed in the mainstream so the human
gifts I mean a lot of us think okay well
humans are creative and that is a gift
and that's true but actually even in a
domain like math we had the first
automated their improver in 1956 called
the logic theorist it's kind of a dawn
of artificial intelligence and we
thought we had our deep blue moment we
just humans were surpassed at math turns
out 60 years later humans are at the
pinnacle so one of the human gifts is
creativity even in very logical
mathematical domains like math itself at
making these nonlinear creative leaps
where we're coming up with theorems that
we intuitively know are correct and then
we eventually fill in the steps and
prove them and so both generating
theorems that are true that we
eventually prove people like Richard
Fineman in physics where he would come
up with theories or explanations and it
would frustrate other math physicists to
the point or one of them disparagingly
called him one of the great
intuitionists of our era and that was a
subtle dig at the fact that it took
other people to fill in the steps
sometimes and Einstein himself people
actually you know he didn't fill in all
the steps in the proofs because he was
just so brilliant intuitively so I mean
some of the gifts are creativity but
even in very engineering or mathematical
domains and and then a host of other
things that come from our embodied
cognition so we grow up and run
thousands or millions of experiments
trial and error interacting with our
environment we have this intense
curiosity and drive to understand the
world as well as intense drive for a
physical agency to be able to manipulate
and modulate it and with those to
whatever environment I mean I think we
have so much plasticity that it's
interesting to think if we were born on
Mars or somewhere else like we probably
could to a certain degree adapt yeah and
and so AI doesn't do that today I mean
you could think way in the future where
baby robots that
adapt and learn through trial and error
and develop a embodied cognition of the
world but today they certainly don't do
anything near that they mostly passively
learned from massive massive datasets
and we live in a real-time world with
physical interactions social
interactions and so there's just this
massive gulf between the two and they
give rise to different gifts and
different strengths that are really
complementary when you get down to its
site and that's what I think is very
untapped both from a technology
investment perspective but also from
just an awareness perspective when the
some of the fears about AI that wouldn't
look makes me really want to cry it's so
beautiful really it's gorgeous
there's an edge of knowledge that we've
been pushing for so long as humans and
that there are a lot of times that's
really deep sometimes it feels like it's
just God channeling through us and for
us to push that edge
we're like intuiting what is beyond the
edge of knowledge that we know and then
everyone says that's [ __ ] ridiculous
your net it's impossible it's not gonna
happen and then the burden of geniuses
is on us in a sense to just stick with
it and to and to push into push and push
into propose these these super
contrarian outside-of-the-box ways of
thinking and then again it's like
sometimes people are so damn creative
that they spend all of their time out at
that edge trying to conceptualize and
come up with new ways to push it and
then they're like can we have some
assistance from people to actually make
those incremental steps that are needed
to hypothesize and to prove or
repeatedly that that is actually true
mm-hmm I love that it just it really
just takes me until all of the ways that
we've just made ideas and have made it
life better by by pushing that edge over
time and
so then maybe some of the ways that a
ice gift right now at least is to do
things that are maybe a little bit more
on like narrow intelligence totally and
I mean the ability to do repetitive
obviously pattern recognition on
datasets well beyond human reach and
also to be more consistent so like
perfectly repetitive pattern recognition
that doesn't part of our gift as humans
in fact is that our memories are
actually always changing every time we
retrieve like content and wrestlin
memory we contextualize it to who we're
now telling it to or the room we're in
and sometimes that's good sometimes it's
not good sometimes you do want perfect
consistency and yes so the strengths of
AI to take massive volumes of data but
then the another the more empowering
strength I think is the ability to
offload some of the menial intellectual
housekeeping that a lot of us are stuck
doing and actually help us have a lens
unto ourselves where we start to it's
like when you learn a second language
and you start to understand syntax and
grammar and symbols and meaning and you
see a second Intel form of intelligence
and we start to understand the taxonomy
of intelligence yeah let's start that
maybe understand ourself I think a lot
of us think humans like intelligence is
one of the gifts that tends to set us
apart in certain realms and but so maybe
getting a lens to understand that
betters is a really empowering area and
then further I feel like men many of us
are living in almost like a little bit
of a dystopia with illusions of freewill
and are stuck doing things are driven by
different external forces and what if
you could unlock from some of that to
really pursue your your own fulfilling
and creative pursuits what a profound
way to look at what is this intelligence
explosion that's happened with AI
because it gives us a new way of looking
at
our own intelligence for really like you
said the first we need that second
language you understand your the first
language better and how it works
same thing with our own intelligence now
that we have an AI we understand our own
intelligence a little bit more because I
like that a lot
I also like what you said about children
too I liked how you it's just so true
that children are these little
scientists and that they're always like
hypothesizing and you know and imagining
and tinkering and and understanding and
their mirroring a lot of the things that
the parents and community are doing
around them and so mrs. though like they
themselves have this infinite creative
potential and then we filed them into
the economic machinery that usually
squashes the creative potential and so
like what is the new paradigm for taking
the useful creative spirit and just like
having it flourish from age five to ten
to fifteen to twenty instead of you know
file it into little you know filling
these bubbles on these tests and then
and then go do work that doesn't give
you fulfillment or meaning in life
so it's a whole new change and it's
gorgeous because it feels like
Millennials and Gen Z are basically
sniffing out the [ __ ] and they're
sniffing out the archaic lines of code
and they're saying enough with that this
is the new paradigm this is where we're
going this is what we're doing mm-hmm
it's really exciting okay now what then
are you looking at with neocortex
ventures in sandbox like who are some of
the organizations that you're like aha
yes we will either give you our mentor
Network in our acceleration space here
or we want to invest in what you're
doing how do you how are you picking
those and like give us some examples
yeah well it's usually it's a two-way
thing we want to make sure that we
obviously that any and in the sandbox to
start with you know will companies will
come in and maybe pitch where they're at
what they've built whether they have a
pilot customer or what status they're at
and that
thing and we'll assess do we think you
know do we think this is the right
potential we can't accept everyone so
sudden there's going to be some
filtering of that maybe it's we think
it's a great idea but it's too early or
too late or whatever it is but then the
second part is can we help them and
actually that's almost more important
we'll look at is this a consumer play
here we only do business to business
enterprise we just don't have the
experience in would be the business to
consumer we'll look at what vertical is
it in do we have enough expertise in
that is a hardware software we tend to
lead more towards software although
we've now had some hybrid startups one
examples in life science where there's a
hardware and a software component
there's another one dealing with that so
so some of them aren't hard and fast
filters but so it's like can we can we
help them and do we think they fit our
profile of the startup we're looking to
plug in some examples we have we have a
synthetic biology startup that's doing
optimizing DNA printing with some
machine learning processes it's a kind
of a trial and error thing that goes
through temperature gradients when you
print DNA essentially by assembling
these Allah goes together into strands
of DNA and so a lot of things where
machine learning is going in and maybe
changing or disrupting a market and it
tends to be very vertical applications
as well so like machine learning and
Industry X you mentioned narrow earlier
so they do tend to be very narrow in
nature with neocortex ventures my
investment thesis is sort of twofold one
is definitely that for the foreseeable
future sort of you know two to three
years I still think narrow AI plays are
are going to be the most successful
meaning AII in this industry or AI in
that industry horizontal platform plays
across industries I think eventually
we'll get there but I don't think we're
quite there now and at least that's not
what I would I personally target the
augmented intelligence is another key
focus and that one is an interesting one
because it is so new
that it takes no one is really
describing themself is that or I think
they're actually just starting to one
encouraging thing is that I mean the
book came out October 20 2018 so last
year and Gartner just put out a report
in the last week saying that they
actually forecast augmented intelligence
will be a two point nine trillion dollar
industry yeah and to me that's
encouraging because I feel like we've
been needing a wake-up call and it's
it's it was very encouraging
usually dot numbers like that will be a
wake-up call so I think this will help
with some of these companies right now
if I if I find one they're probably not
calling themself that so it takes more
digging and curation to find them and
you're calling it augmented intelligence
augment intelligence yeah okay and then
that in the Augmented intelligence is
human AI collaboration that's correct
yeah ok and then ok so you gave us some
of the examples on on sandbox and your
cortex ventures now maybe give us some
of the these optimal ways that you
already see it happening as well as
where you see it going where human gifts
and AI gifts are synergizing into a
center yes definitely
well I and I like the Centaur cuz this
hybrid being had powers greater than the
sum of the parts right like it was like
this sort of super human being and I do
think that the whole is greater than the
sum of the parts they kind of a human's
augment the ai ai ai augments the humans
and you get this one plus one is greater
than two
and so so yeah in terms of I guess the
examples of that
are you guys going to particular like
specific examples of that right now yeah
let's do it yeah so I think it is
definitely a newer domain I'm seeing
some of the former people that were in
the SR I project behind like dark the
DARPA funded a project originally called
pal and they called it Kayla which is
cognitive assistant that learns and
organizes and so that like the voice
assistant was sore
of a sliver of what the potential was so
now it's like how do we you know get the
rest of the 99% of the vision of that
and some of that would be for example if
you think about all the text we deal
with so some NLP incorporation into that
where we can offload if you had like a
hundred assistants that you could say go
research these things and bring you back
the results you could go so much faster
in coming up with hypotheses running and
producing outputs and that kind of thing
so NLP is definitely one of the key
areas I've been focusing on that but I
think I think there's a whole a whole
bunch of them so they're gonna be coming
out here shortly and then where would it
where does it feel like intuitively that
like out of the dislike this perspective
like three trillion dollar future of
augmented intelligence like where is it
going to be most most common most
evident but also just most useful like
where's the greatest utility with it
like right now we already have these
incredible cameras and this incredible
audio capturing system the distribution
system on it with the information
technology infrastructure we have these
computers already in phones that are
segmenting us so tremendously what else
like are like on the voice side of
things the units are now in so many
homes and offices all over the place
lights this color I feel this way it
changed the mood like this and we spray
some scent in the room change mood you
know but music always like yeah well
documented reality a virtual reality
transition that we're going through as
well and how that's augmenting our
intelligence so we aware where will it
be that that you know that AI is maybe
picking up some of the the patterns and
that they're giving you know these
useful insights into humans like we also
talked about our
metric states like yeah we're weird yet
where you going yeah no it's it's really
interesting I mean I feel actually have
a slightly contrarian perspective on
that because I feel like a lot of the
technology described email smartphones
notifications social networks text
messages is actually knocking us out of
our core gifts so I feel like we've
actually created an environment today
where we're undermining our number-one
gift and strength which is is the
creativity the Eureka moments the
epiphanies that we have and so if we're
moving to a chapter which I think we
definitely are where menial low-level
repetitive stuff is no longer gonna be
value-adding we're gonna moving up a
value chain where these epiphanies and
Eureka moments are really gonna be our
key gift it's not going to be just
assembling things in assembly line for
12 hours a day which I don't think is
really empowering for anyone to do so if
if our if these creative sparks are our
gift I think my hope for the next
generation of technology is going to be
we figure away reduce the distractions
like almost all this tech driven by
advertising is designed to capture your
attention I think we understand the
attention economy and we're surrounded
by tech that's that's zapping us out of
that so the next wave what I think would
be much more empowering is finding the
better balance where if you want to opt
in for this period of time to this
notification driven world where people
expect instant responses on text and
email and status reports but what if you
had tech that you could actually
delegate some of that so in another
example is in a lot of work environments
you have to produce status reports on a
regular basis and for me that knocks me
out of creative flow State right hmm I'm
sitting there Jam and oh I got a report
to the boss it's Friday I got to tell
them what I've done what I haven't done
easy task for AI something that's
working with us monitoring us auto
produced those status reports
communicate it get rid of low-level
distractive communication and emails
when you want the social part we're all
social beings that's when you opt in
and you go and you socialize and you
have conversations but when you're in
your flow state is not when you should
be interrupted with that so that's
that's one key area I'm so happy that
you ventured us into that point it's
like we're in this beautiful pinnacle
creative flow state that we do not want
interrupted and then we're like being
demanded art our attentions being
demanded in other domains and it's just
what is the right way you said there was
this like idea of maybe like an opt-in
so maybe like I don't even know how I
could handle this opt-in thing I don't
know cuz like flicking on the switch on
to receiving notifications in itself is
already tremendously overwhelming for me
period already off the bat phone's
always on silent every single
notification on every single app is off
social apps deleted from the device
unneeded unnecessary total period and
you know when you message me it does not
mean that you will get a reply even the
same day or the same week for that kick
in that case I'm gonna create a flow
state I'm doing things that are aligned
with my North Star if that comes in in a
certain way that it needs to be
addressed immediately because it's it's
oh oh it's also very funny it's like
totally you know as above so below this
very spiritual principle very nature
oriented principle it's also very true
about our communication like as above so
below in the sense that not only does
someone message me and I'm like I can't
reply to that it's a no way I can reply
to that well the same thing happens to
me all the time I'm reaching out to
people way smarter than me and I'm not
getting reply so so so true as a book so
below
and and that's that but that's the way
that it that's the way is rules and we
have to we have to admire that also as
we reach out to people that are smarter
than us that are more influential than
us that they're in their creative flow
States and they can't also reply to
everybody that's reaching out to them
I'm really happy that you mentioned the
ways to automate these things to like
the reports those reports are like right
now we have we have an intern that's
working with us and like do that weekly
report that I have to fill it doesn't
even matter if it takes three or five
minutes because it doesn't actually only
take three or five minutes it also is
the switching cost totally you have to
switch yourself from the flow State to
the dude thing three to five minutes
there but all your firing and wiring an
activity that was happening in the flow
state it's not just gonna immediately
pop back to its state that it was in
it's gonna take you a long it's like
trying to get the car from zero to sixty
again mm-hmm and now during the week
you're thinking ahead cuz you know you
have to produce that report so there's a
river yes and and the other one is
there's a bunch of a bunch of these like
like X dot a is another one that's
really interesting it's doing the email
automation like as long as I just say
yes to my email assistant for scheduling
a meeting between Alex and I then from
there I don't do anything did literally
the assistant will work with you or even
better your assistant mmm-hmm Bertrille
assistant totally I assisted and they'll
just find Wednesday at nine a.m. and
that's it and it's just like that like
it just appears on our calendars and
we're like thank goodness we didn't have
to do that I think that itself will be
freeing for me I mean I have a stress
response to calendar scheduling because
for especially for that two-year period
I was almost always triple-booked so I'm
always writing these oh I'm so sorry
apologetic emails and it's a little
stressful but and so freeing yourself
from bringing myself at least from
calendaring I would so be so happy to
delegate that and then you know going
higher up the
you chain if you had an AOL partner they
can do sketching that's great some low
level stuff what if you had a private
and this is something called teaming or
human AI not just personal assistant but
like scientific code collaborator
co-founder at that level something that
new your entire life's history of
writing and intellectual thought yeah I
mean transformative right and looming on
the horizon but part of my push to
accelerate it is to really get there and
get that out so it's not only a digital
twin of Alex Bates to be able to do
things like see okay like let's run a
simulation of what happens if Alex works
out every day for one hour for the next
week and see what happens to his
productivity snoozy ology his life
outcome all this stuff along jeopardy
but if then it's also like can we
literally have Alex have a one-hour
meeting with this digital twin whereas
digital twin like purposely like pokes
you and the spots that maybe you need to
really work on your own self growth in
your self development like your triggers
and stuff but then also like place like
intellectual creative tennis with you on
the ideas that you have and all of a
sudden you're like whoa that was epic I
just learned so much it's like a
compression algorithm for creativity for
I love it so it's like a virtual
assistant a virtual medical coach
virtual intellectual scientific
collaborator creative collaborating
coach spiritual collaborating coach and
what you even mentioned alludes to maybe
almost like a life coach like it's a
combination of things
where and some people think of
significant others and partners is so on
for the fulfilling some of this and
certainly they do but it actually puts
too much pressure on another person to
be your therapist life coach code
collaborator I think actually it could
freeze some of our relationships yes so
much pressure of that but the
possibility here you even alluded to
like some of the nudging that could
happen we there's this book the paradox
of choice we like freedom we
like choice if I have to make fifty
choices in a day I'm just exhausted even
what to dress and of course if like
Steve Jobs just wear the same thing
every day
what to eat I mean all these micro
decisions are actually taxing on us so
what if what if we had an AI that could
learn personalized delegate what would
that free us up to have the the
willpower and an energy left to decide
to do now that we don't have to make 50
micro decisions that are that are
meaningless and so that's an example to
me of where we don't yet have true free
will in some of these areas and the
exciting ability to unlock us and what
would we do with that extra bandwidth I
mean it's it's sky's the limit that's
such a good one
that with our partners and our
relationships we see this happening all
the time
divorce rates are really high people are
pursuing careers and like mimetics
over genetics like their spread of their
ideas rather than the spread of their
genes to a single child oh there's all
these types of like examples of this
where it's like the it's both a gorgeous
idea of like oh I found this like you
know twin flame or the soulmate where we
can just you know help each other grow
so so beautifully in every single domain
and respect like yeah that's like that's
possible exists and like you can totally
get that and whatnot but like you also
realize that you have a North Star and
they have a North Star and you have to
also you know create both as you create
together you also create independently
and away from one another and that there
are ways that that they can just not
optimally optimize you like you can
optimize yourself more effectively
through a really powerfully trained AI
coach and I think that that's like
hands-down something that a lot of
people are really excited about and and
also just like it's gonna be really
important that it's trained well like
there was the the other recent delivery
of something that was really profoundly
awakening which was that if he is just
training like a
uuugh training facebook on who you are
based on your likes
over 300 of them and they know you
better than you know yourself or your
partner knows you there's like how many
yeah how much how much internet activity
does it take for the AI to know me
better than I know myself like AI know
is the last time that you know I visited
this specific site or that I bought this
certain thing better than I remember it
and then it's like you know if I'm
trying to say that oh I haven't done
that in a while they're like no you did
it last week mhm it's like you can't
just say that you know that you went on
a run last week because you haven't been
on a run in a month yeah yeah yeah that
was such a fast name in the Cambridge
analytic or the five-factor
ocean model of profiling that was used
with your likes - yeah no no more about
your parents there's nipi another and it
works shockingly well and of course was
used for some elections but I think the
knee-jerk reaction to that was we need
to shut everything down and go back to
the Middle Ages of privacy I think you
can guess where I'm gonna come out on
this position I understand where they're
coming from but I also feel like
regressing in the face of fear that we
could be manipulated you can either do
one of two things you can say I'm going
to cut off from the world and live in a
castle with a moat or you can say I'm
gonna try to uplift myself to understand
myself better so I'm less susceptible to
manipulation because I slit we're still
social creatures we want to get out
there's always a chance we can be
manipulated or taken advantage of and
what if we could evolve and transcend
our own capabilities so that we're just
more resistant than you and I think
obviously that's the side I would be on
and so likewise and so you know looking
at the next evolution from that another
uplifting thing for me is AI combined
with this area called neuro tech and I
know you've talked to a number of people
in this space and of course we met
physically at the brain mind yes meeting
for the first time in person and that
consortium so the neuro tech is a step
change it's looming even the there's
some people in the AI can either very
skeptical actually about about humans
they're like
we're here now the obsolete in a decade
and I don't fall into that camp I know
some of these people they're good people
I think maybe in a couple centuries or
so on and of course will it be humid I
the transcendent thing comes out and
symbiosis but but you know what so so
there's the skeptics think we'll having
a role but neuro tech so neuro tech and
AI neuro tech will be a step change
where our human computer human AI
interface evolves from a keyboard a
mouse and a little square screen to
direct communication and incredibly
empowering so and actually one other
thing that excites me is there's this
area of teaming research and DARPA has a
new project teaming could actually be
human to human like the Apollo program
actually like the Manhattan Project and
the Manhattan Project tracks nuclear
energy in three years it's kind of
mind-boggling when you look back you
know it was like 30 core scientists and
then a bigger team of 300 but what if we
could all have our own Manhattan
projects and figure out what's the best
collaboration brainstorming even some
like cognitive dissonance like there's
the person on the team that you know you
really have to prove it and they have a
competing theory and then eventually you
lock in on the actual solution and so
human to human human to AI I'm super
excited about the intersection of neuro
tech and AI and we talked about the
empowerment the self insight so most of
this data now is because it's used for
advertising is he's for a manipulation
to either get attention or to buy
products what if it was used to give us
neurofeedback biofeedback insight into
ourselves and at that point we'd all be
more resistant to manipulation because
we'd actually understand ourselves
better so beautifully synthesized again
so there's the there's this like it's
it's now becoming more more prevalent
it's so interesting it went from the the
gdpr
it went from that to
like there's also like the decent like
hyper authoritarian let all the data
flow to the to the authoritarian regime
of the country or whatever and then
there's the like absolutely I'm moving
to the middle of the forest no way ever
will I ever let them ever data data my
data my data this protect I and the most
thing that you were giving an example
about there's like there's like it's
like every scenario that's being
basically Illustrated is one of its it
has some sort of a fear response to it
all of them almost do and the like we
need to paint the one that's filled with
a love the one that's filled with peace
the one that's filled with self and
collective actualization we need to
paint that one and make that the most
vivid and then drive our resources to
that one and then make that one the one
that happens and maneuv you data to just
try to build a social fabric where I
trust my biometrics my psycho metrics my
everything to flow therefore it to be a
really good coach for me on medical on
North Star coach all this type of stuff
and you did also point out how on the
neuro tech side that one's extremely
beautiful I mean these these devices
have already been neuro tech in a sense
the phones and the computers are already
a massive addition to our cognitive
capabilities and capacities you would
you'd be you'd be surprised at how just
like 20 years ago without like the
democratization of these devices so so
ubiquitously that when you know when we
wanted to to look something up when we
weren't near like a computer you know
what would we do just go to the library
go to you know it's like a PTO or
whatever it was and and like now it's as
easy as just saying it to the voice
device and asking them the question
about about what we want to learn about
I mean like the speed at which
we are all men ting ourselves already
with the with the technologic
technologic iterations moving away from
meat sticks on keyboards towards ya
towards it's like it's really beautiful
I always think about this because I
myself have to edit it edit a tremendous
amount of video for the show but you
know just like using any of the video
editing softwares with a keyboard and a
mouse is just just think about the next
step so the next steps are like you know
throwing in the time like these clips
from the from the video with you know
without space and meters of literally
just throwing them into this you know to
this beautiful three-dimensional visual
digital space and then for me to be able
to take them and just so easily just
adjust them with my fingers in the space
and and and furthermore is and the
thought is just with thought I can then
go and edit these videos and make
creative beautiful pieces of content
with just my thoughts then you also gave
the example of the team as well I can
you literally get you know how can you
in just it was so through those three
years at the Manhattan Project and 30
people with a how many total 300 500 and
then there's bigger support teams but
core teams of scientists partly due to
confidentiality and compartment ation
but did almost shock and they pulled
this off in such a short period of time
like what is possible if the pressure is
cooking so much and especially like they
didn't have what we have now with the
corpus of all knowledge being available
on the internet so it's like yeah what
is what is possible now like you have
this beautiful idea writers is it yeah
this is a gorgeous idea that you want to
execute in the world but it's like kind
of overwhelming because you know you
have to take all of these crazy long
steps to get there but also you also
know that you may have a second one and
a third
one that come up later along the way
what if we could compress that time by
having the AI coaches and assistants
along the way to help us get to that
first Northstar that beautiful release
of something creative and then just go
to the next one instead of only do one
in a lifetime maybe into three or five
totally yeah I mean it's amazing to
think because you think about types of
augmentation first of all I think we'll
start to get a better understanding of
our own of creativity and our own what
makes us most creative and something
that can actually personalize our
environment for our own peak creative
moments and so that would be hugely
uplifting and then also the the
interface aspect so it could be that the
speed of thought so they say that when
you dream it's in hyper speed like in
the movie Inception and part of reason
they think is there's no sensory input
and part of our perception of time as
all the sensory input so it does kind of
slow down when you can process without
that it's like you're operating the
faster speed and so if you think this is
kind of get a lot there but what if you
could be brainstorming and you weren't
having to move mice and keyboards but
your brain was directly getting feedback
it would be like you're dreaming but in
an awake State maybe you could think 10
times faster we don't really know yet
I know Elon Musk the recent announcement
with the neural link of course addresses
the bandwidth bottleneck so that is when
the bus we got the spinal cord sensory
motor control and that's our interface
to the real world but what if you could
so first of all he's looking at tapping
of the brain but even for the
input/output aspect where we do our
brainstorming and that kind of thing
that can all be greatly enhanced and and
so the neuro tech things that are
happening I love how Elon is is very
impatient I mean in the good sense where
I'm not going to wait a decade you're
actually piloting next year and I know
people that we met at brain mine that
are going to be implanting semi invasive
chips next year in their own brain
because that's the only way to do it
right now so they're gonna run it on
themselves but that path to me is going
to be just an absolute game changer
for our interface to AI and each other
damn what a profound way to think about
it it's just that like if you think
about yourself in the dream state it's
like what's going on in that state with
a lack of light you know he's like the
physical input stream that's happening
like why does it look what's going on
with time and with my input stream in
the dream space and like how much
quicker
could I and the you know not have the
bottleneck of needing to go down my
spinal cord to move the mouse in the
specific direction that I want to move
in and then get the feedback back of
what I did and back up back up and
through what I through what happened or
through tactical you know just get it
back up just what if it just how much
faster could it be and what would what
would I be able to achieve and okay
let's talk about this what about you
know handling this in a way that is like
spiritually evolved because this is
what's tough is that we have monkey
politics still happening around the
planet and we know that we're kind of
sick of it like where we are we're just
we're sick of monkey politics we're sick
of of people not treating our planet
like it's the thing that gives us life
and that sustains us we're sick of we're
sick of like depending on something that
is exogenously
for our own divine potential like that I
need some sort of a religion or a
government or something that that versus
me being able to discover myself that I
am God within God and that I don't and
that if we all discover that we won't
need a government to take care of things
among us so that our lack of then that
spiritual evolution is so evidently
visible in all the issues we have in our
world are disconnected from nature and
sources the reason why we have so many
the issues so how can we be trusted to
to behave benevolently towards each
other when we put
in our brains what are your thoughts
about that
well another fascinating question and
and I actually do okay to discuss
spiritual matters even relative to AI
it's it's but and I think it's really
interesting so I was actually talking to
Daniel credit who founded the empathy
lab at Google and we're talking about so
you have EQ and empathy and how can
computers play in this space and some
people are thinking the state of the art
is reading every microexpression
and inferring what your effective
emotional state is and she said no
actually a better goal is like Ram Dass
changing the channel where we treat each
other almost as like spiritual beings we
have our own life journey that gave us
probably some imprints that made us who
we are now but instead of trying to
understand every micro response to
things we said or misinterpretations
what if we just changed the channel to a
higher level of awareness and
interaction something that the tech
committee would normally not think about
it all but actually in a blew me away
when she said that but it actually it is
it is fascinating like the goal isn't
really to deal with micro expressions
and micro emotions it's it's to have all
of us evolve to a higher level I do
think that the neurofeedback and AI sort
of partner is part of that journey
because to get to a spiritual level part
of it is understanding ourselves and
maybe unlocking from some things in our
past maybe it's some traumatic things we
go through childhood it's such a random
process certain things have an imprints
are made and it has massive impact later
in life and in general I think we all
have certain types of freewill and
certain types of spirituality but a lot
of us are drawn back by some of these
things and so ability to get more of
that self insight and to really evolve
and transcend and there's a lot of ways
to talk about transcendence but I think
technology definitely can be part of
that that journey your respond on that
changing the channel to see each other
as spiritual divine beings that all have
our own beautiful note
that we're playing in the symphony or a
beautiful paint stroke that we're doing
on the canvas of creation viewing it
that way it transforms you forever if
you're a guy you no longer just look at
a woman's physical features you you
start thinking about their spirit and
what their purpose is if you are oh if
you are if you are a person of any like
skin color from around the world you
don't fear other people for their skin
color but rather you wonder what
happened to them growing up that that
that is different philosophical II or
morally than when where I grew up
because it was from a different part of
the world that had a different
philosophy and a different upbringing so
it's like do you just you start seeing
things differently and then that you can
never go back to the to the old ways and
what's that once that happens so like
turning up the channel on spirituality
around the planet will eradicate the the
potentiality of malevolence --is as we
go into the exponential technology age I
mean hundred percent because if you
think about augmenting seven point seven
billion people to superhuman levels just
like the Centaur maybe some people if
you have some mental health issues and
some people actually have actually
genetic things which maybe lead to
psychopathy or sociopathy or whatever
and so some it's a combination of nature
and nurture some maybe it actually is
pure nature and they just are wired some
people don't have a big deal of
responses for certain things and maybe
in a sense it's not their fault but if
we could understand that and solve the
mental health aspect before we give them
the superhuman augmentation tools yes
then we are moving to a spiritual level
but we're addressing the mental health
issues where they where they occur
addressing traumas where they occur so
that we all are sort of in a naturalized
state now we're ready to take that leap
and maybe be augment in to that level so
I think obviously that's part of the the
journey and the solution there but but
yeah it's really interesting to think
about how it's almost most people think
of spirituality is the opposite of
technology but I see it as is a tool to
unlock
from some things that are actually
limiting us from being more spiritual
there's no other way than to beautifully
mesh together spirituality and science
there's just no other way those two
things are hand-in-hand the most
important things for us to just fully
embody and intertwine and actualize
that's like that's what God that's what
creation wants us to remember that we
come from source and that as we
intellectualize and break apart the atom
into its smallest components and as we
understand the brain of its smallest
components and we keep doing that
process that remember that you also come
from source and remember that you have a
spiritual purpose here that you've come
to that we've all come to do on this
beautiful symphony / painting of art of
creation there's no other way they have
to come together we literally are in you
know Silicon Valley silicon beach what's
San Diego's name I mean Beach ish but
then emerge that overlaps LA so to be
determined I think we're trying to
actually call SoCal silicon [ __ ] thing
because Silicon Valley if it includes
San Francisco we we're perspective is LA
and San Diego are part of the same
collective and Silicon Valley gets
lumped together like like SF and Oakland
and San Jose and North Bay and sometimes
Monterey and Santa Cruz and stuff so
like fine and a SoCal can have silicon
Beach be San Diego in LA thank you like
every single team in Silicon Valley in
silicon beach especially because in
silicon beach you have Hollywood along
with all the tech which has a lot of
entertainment power to spread memes
around the world but Silicon Valley
obviously has these massive tech giants
and whatnot that every single one of
those teams needs to have a philosopher
an ethicist moral scientists spiritual
leaders meditation leaders psychedelic
trainers signal psychotherapists I'm
saying like
to be a suite of spiritual actualization
philosophy and ethicists that are every
single one of these massive companies
and Hollywood's period period otherwise
we are opening up the fragmentation of
our spirit to accidentally allow the
malevolence is to come through we're
accidentally by not thinking well enough
in advance
opening up the potentials for it I mean
it's so true there's such a power for
storytelling and movies is such a
visceral way to tell stories I also
think that when you talk about like
impact and bringing all those people and
perspectives to make sure this is as a
positive kind of endpoint even for
investing I heard one investor made a
comment I like to invest in one of the
seven deadly sins and he think about
social networks so I think there's
there's an awakening happening in the
investment community about the
importance of impact investing and just
impact not just pure economic
bottom-line right people and plan it and
it's interesting to think about the
power of Hollywood and storytelling that
also they're actually obviously recently
they've been struggling cranking out
blockbusters some of them come out but
they've had a lot of a lot of duds and
maybe people are tired of the the old
stories and the deadly sense maybe let's
try to evolve that thinking - that's
that's a really great idea what about
your relationship with source what is
that like my relationship is it's been a
journey actually when I was a young
engineer everything was ones and zeroes
and engineering and that's all it
mattered there was no such thing as
really psychology beyond like low-level
behaviors and BF Skinner studies and so
on and I as I grew up and evolved and
matured a little bit the concept of the
W something actually wisdom right you
brought up wisdom earlier and
spirituality and source early on my
perspective was I guess where like I'm
an agnostic it's unknowable so don't
even spent too much time thinking about
it but as I've gotten older I've become
a lot more curious about it I def
we believe in some greater order I mean
there you can interpret that number of
ways I feel like the reason I'm so
passionate about trying to understand
the universe and AI is one tool to do
that is I do think there's some
beautiful meaning to it that we're just
like an ant on the shore right now
looking out and it's a long journey to
even come close to starting to think
that but one is appreciating that beauty
and that the unknowns but the other part
of me wants to quickly transcend the
human limitations to where we can just
get a little bit closer I mean the
low-level things are we in a simulation
are there other forms of intelligent
life out there but the meaning of life
in the universe and getting closer to
the source I think the source would
embrace that yeah and to me science and
engineering are one of many tools but
are not like antithetical or heretical
to that that journey and then what about
your relationship with the the way that
free will and determinism interplay hmm
another great one okay I'm a big
believer in the free will can exist I
don't think everything is determined I
do think that a lot of us have illusions
of the amount of free will we have and
and everything from getting better self
insight but also better insight into the
universe and and things that happen like
I say to each one of us in our life
journey and understanding the universe
as a whole will give us so much more
freedom and I think a lot of us spend so
much for life buffeted by things
happening and some of them are beautiful
and spontaneous but others are are
things that are just disempowering or or
stressful so how do we what is the
optimal like once we start to have more
freedom and and to pursue more creative
and fulfilling things what will that
look like and how will we use that
freedom I think is going to be really
interesting
you know I think we're just at the cusp
of starting to understand her stand and
explore that but I look forward to
having more of it does it feel as though
there are forces that are at play on the
planet that are channeling through us
onto this board game that is planet
Earth like sort of good and bad yes like
that the Star Wars the dark side well I
actually feel like I don't know if I
caught forces I think that each of us
has a potential for good or bad I think
that some people have had traumatic
experiences or or just mental illness
that do things that we think of as bad
or evil or not empathetic and some of
them weren't parented well and were
raised in toxic households and they lash
out when they're older and we're like
that person is a horrible human being
should even be around but if if we can
all I guess what I call it evil I mean
when you look at someone's entirety of
their nature their nurture where they
grew up and doesn't necessarily excuse
the bad behavior but you start to
understand okay here's all the things
that led up to that I like to zoom out
and say for all these people that do
these bad things that we don't want to
have how can we solve the things that
happen their child or their parenting
may be genetics in some cases and how
can how can we solve those problems and
then maybe there wouldn't be so many
these dark things happening in terms of
whether it is I don't believe in like
sort of like a you know a seitan type
thing in fact I mean in the
Enlightenment a lot of the scientists
were burned at the stake for tapping
into the dark force and committing
witchcraft and of course everything
seems like witchcraft will you
understand how it works so I don't
believe in that kind of dark force but
yeah I think I I guess like as we move
up to almost really almost godlike
capabilities as we look at this
augmentation path it brings up a whole
new set of
and ethics almost if you could bring
back an extinct species shed you should
you bring back all extinct species do we
need to create a million there's like a
bunch of brand new questions come out
that are kind of crazy to think about
and even good and bad like here's the
crazy thing someone recent old me they
were glad they went to a really bad
school that with gangs and so on because
it gave them character and that flips
the whole thinking like do we need to go
through some tough episodes to then get
to the other side and appreciate and
have gratitude yeah those are
complicated questions I can't say I have
the answer cuz I love those questions
that though do the roots need to reach
down to hell for the leaves and fruits
to reach the heavens as such a good
question I all the way to fit that you
know that's a really really tough one
and on the other side of the greatest
traumas are the greatest treasures would
we get those treasures if there weren't
traumas who knows I mean that's that's a
really give you're born into a utopia
like a perfect world and it's just like
you're just trying to incrementally make
the do you topia better it's like is it
like oh why is that like is that perfect
is that a perfect creation where is this
actually a perfect creation yeah that's
hilarious actually that's a great that
then he's so funny to for me to like
finish the question about free will or
determinism and you're like deep
question that he'd you like look at it I
don't often do that sometimes some would
ask me a question yeah cuz that also
shows you know humility cuz it's a
really hard if these are really tough
tough questions okay let's ask one of
the toughest questions which is what is
it teleology of our species like what is
the purpose or the meaning of life yeah
another great one I mean to me I think
humans have this quest for expiration on
the one hand we don't like change and
we're fearful of change and things that
shake things up
yeah we have this deep thirst for
expiration and also understanding and
understand the world and universe around
us in terms of purpose
I think definitely striving up almost up
to God like just understand the universe
understanding the purpose the source as
you call it and I mean I remember eating
taro to shut down talking about the the
noosphere and right now I mean when we
start to understand we're a bunch of
atoms and they're actually comprised
into a bunch of cells we're actually a
trillion cells that don't know who we
are and they're all buzzing around and
getting their energy and and splitting
and all this crazy stuff and then we're
this emergent phenomenon and now there's
seven point seven billion of us on the
planet and so that's one path of each of
us maybe transcending our limits I
actually feel like self-awareness isn't
really the end game it's actually maybe
a higher level of group consciousness or
beyond just our boundaries right and
then when you get into the physics you
talked it earlier the boundary is
actually not so concrete and when you
think about memetics and thought and so
on I think there's trans set like
becoming more human by transcending
human limits I feel like is one of our
purposes oh I love that line we as eight
billion cells it can realize the full
collective consciousness that we all
make up and then for that to fully
realize itself as source being that that
rather than just the individual cells
realizing but the whole collective ooh
that's a good one it's good and then and
then making more cells like could a
hundred billion cells be in the cosmos
peak being creative having meaning
having consciousness and all realizing
that they're coming from source what a
freaking cool creation this is I
remember I was hanging out at the friend
recently and I and I said I said
something this is with great confidence
but also great humility I said source
and creation is gorgeous and beautiful
but we can make something
better they were and they got a little
upset but I see where you're coming
there's still Sardis though another case
it couldn't that's an Ouroboros even
that's what mmm we just meet the next
one and it just let it yeah yeah yeah
how many layers are we in a simulation
Alex almost back to sort of the agnostic
thing a fascinating question I think it
is answerable with with AI so it's pure
speculation without too much data it
doesn't feel like one to me but is I
could be an assimilation I wouldn't a
Sara Lee feel like like it was so I mean
all the studies I've seen you can find
these glitches or defects I think really
the only path to answering it is
augmentation and and just accelerating
our intelligence to levels like
trillions but beyond what we are today
to answer that that one in the
intelligent extraterrestrial life are
ones that burn at me yeah so I'd be I'd
love to speed up the answers to those
you're gonna yeah evolved from cricket
intelligence to be able to answer those
questions better thank you yeah yeah
yeah good way to put it and then what is
the most beautiful thing in the world
mmm I mean to me seeing a fully seeing
when people become so actualized and and
fulfilled that the the love for everyone
around them and and their respect and
gratitude appreciation for the present
moment whether it's seeing your child
playing in a playground or someone
else's child or just humanity as a whole
like appreciating nature to me like that
level of both gratitude lack of judgment
just acceptance we all talked about sort
of accepting where spiritual beings life
is spiritual the universe may be
spiritual and it's realizing how
beautiful that all is to me is is that
it would be able you
whole thing so beautifully said and this
has just been one of my favorite
interviews thank you Alex it's been such
a pleasure thank you so much for coming
on the show really amazing as always I
love your work and really enjoyed this
so much thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you everyone for tuning
in we greatly appreciate it we'd love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
on the episode also let us know what
you're thinking about the conversations
that we had today about human AI
collaboration about the future of the
Augmented mind and augmented humans
merging together with AI and
collaborating have more conversation to
your friends your families co-workers
people online on social media about that
be at the cutting edge of that
conversation and let us know your
thoughts in the comments about those
topics as well also check out the links
in the bio below go check out neocortex
ventures Calm check out the sandbox.a I
come and visit if you're local in the
San Diego area come and visit and also
check out the augmented mind book link
as well highly recommend checking that
out and also support the artists the
entrepreneurs the spiritual leaders the
leaders in your community support them
and help them grow support simulation
our links are in the bio below to our
paypal cryptocurrency patreon linking
and design cold merchants you paid all
those links are below help us to
continue doing cool things like coming
on site to San Diego to do interviews
and go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you very much thank you for tuning
in and we will see you soon
that was so good thank you so much
whoa-ah
I absolutely loved there are several
things that you said to or I'm like I'm
so bad you're recording it like you
captured some moments so beautifully we
captured this whole game of tennis
that's yeah that's what we did that's
what this is that's all this is just
capturing games of tennis between two
world views and sharing it with other
people and then having other people go
Walt look at all those like that that
inspired me I know what I'm gonna do
with that
yeah let's transform the minds oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah
that's it